manger des frites deux fois par semaine
voilà le conseil des producteurs belges
de pommes de terre pour tenter de sauver
le secteur depuis le début de la crise
du coronavirus les cultivateurs se
retrouve avec des tonnes de récoltes sur
les bras un coup dur en belgique où cet
aliment constitue un produit qui
s'exporte bien à travers le monde
transforme plus de 5 millions de tonnes
de pommes de terre en est le premier
exportateur mondial de produits ont
expliqué des produits à travers le monde
entier aujourd'hui terminée les
manifestations culturelles et sportives
elles les restaurants les fast food ont
fermé leurs portes la consommation de
pommes de terre a drastiquement chuté
les usines qui habituellement transforme
cette denrée alimentaire sont
actuellement fermés
les stocks augmentent de jour en jour et
les pertes accumulées seront compliqués
à compenser l 750 mille tonnes de pommes
de terre pourrait être perdue d'après ce
qu'on entend les gens qui ont livres de
pommes de terre
ils disent que leur frigo leurs
congélateurs sont plaints donc il n'y a
plus place dont qu il doit vendre le
produit fini pour pouvoir reprendre
notre marche en dise les genres
manchette frites les fasse le tri ou
vrai mais je pense que même si l'ouvrier
tous à 100 % aujourd'hui
le retard que nous avons pris pendant
deux mois ben on va pas savoir le
rattraper parce que celui qui n'a pas
mangé sa portion de frites il ya un mois
il a peut-être raté 3 pour s'offrir va
pas aller chez le marchand de frites en
disant j'en veux cinq demain parce qu'il
n'avait pas mangé carte quoi donc je
pense que le retard on voit jamais
rattrapé les consommateurs n'ont pour
autant pas arrêter complètement la
consommation de pommes de terre avec les
mesures de confinement elles se mangent
aussi à la maison est souvent bien
cuisiner des observateurs ont aussi
remarqué l'explosion de la consommation
de chips dans les ménages pour manger
des bonnes frites
il faudra encore attendre un peu